Otto von Bismarck hat es Auswärtige Amt
gegründet führte die fortschrittlichsten
Sozialgesetze der Welt ein gilt aber
auch als Wegbereiter des deutschen
Kolonialismus er galt mich als Demokrat
der frühere Reichskanzler ist aber Teil
der deutschen Geschichte aber nicht mehr
das Auswärtigen Amts das bismarckzimmer
wird umbenannt heißt jetzt sei der
deutschen Einheit auch das Porträt des
einzigen Reichskanzlers wurde abgehängt
darüber sprechen wir jetzt hier Frau
Kelle wollen damit die Grünen unsere
Geschichte bereinigen sie sind ja schon
dabei es ist ja nicht das erste Mal dass
aus der Öffentlichkeit sagen wir mal
Geschichte oder eben auch Tradition
verbannt wird wir haben zuletzt die
Diskussion über das Humboldt Schloss
über die Bibel Inschrift die ja auch
historisch einfach dort ist wir haben
bei den 7 Treffen haben wir einen
historisches Kreuz aus einem Saal
getragen obwohl sich gar niemand
beschwert hat das heißt wir sind schon
dabei im Endeffekt unsere gesamte
Tradition und das ist die christliche
abendländische Tradition auch
auf den Straßennamen übrigens ja es ist
ja auch jetzt ist ja nicht das erste Mal
dass wir auch quasi das Thema
Kolonialismus meinen löschen zu müssen
auch die Umbenennung ganz vieler Straßen
gehört mit in dieses Konzept hinein und
insofern geschichtslöschung muss ich
sagen ist ein ganz seltsames Gefühl
kommt da auf weil nur totalitäre Regime
haben das bislang gemacht weltweit dass
sie versucht haben die eigene Geschichte
zu eliminieren und sie neu zu schreiben
diese Tendenz muss eigentlich sofort
gestoppt werden als Begründung heißt es
ja man wolle der historischen
Entwicklung des Raumes Rechnung tragen
da fragt man sich was ist daran falsch
man will nicht die Rechnung tragen der
Historie sondern man will die Historie
löschen das ist eine völlig andere
Ambition also man könnte ja sich darüber
unterhalten irgendwie was
aber allerdings über viele Politiker die
Frage ist dann auch wie weit will man
zurückgehen also welchen Teil der
Geschichte will man löschen nach welchen
Kriterien wer ist im Rückblick überhaupt
noch adäquat sind wir es selber in
unsere Kinder uns in 50 Jahren auch
löschen weil wir es falsch gemacht haben
ehrlich sagen wir können auch aus
Geschichte nicht lernen wenn wir die
Geschichte eliminieren normalerweise
lernt man daraus indem man an die
Geschichte erinnert sie aufarbeitet also
eine Frage was würde passieren wenn
jetzt plötzlich eine wie eine Regierung
haben die sagte wir löschen den
Holocaust aus dem Gedächtnis der
Deutschen weil es ist ja jetzt auch
genug und das waren ja sowieso
Verbrecher und wir wollen die eigentlich
gar nicht mehr in unserem historischen
Gedächtnis haben sondern wir machen
jetzt mal Schlussstrich dann wäre der
Aufschrei groß zu Recht ja dass man sagt
wo ist der Unterschied nach welchen
Kriterien wird hier gelöscht und ich
stelle fest dass vor allen Dingen das
christlich christliche Abendland raus
gelöscht wird das ist eine große
Diskussion derzeit Herr Stahl wenn sie
hören dass die Politiker so ein Thema
auf die Agenda setzen wie man das Zimmer
jetzt benennen sollte das ist nicht mehr
Bismarck Zimmer heißt was geht ihnen
dadurch den Kopf dass das überhaupt
jetzt eine Rolle spielt gibt es nicht
wichtigere Probleme fragt man sich aber
die Politik die auf einem grünen und auf
dem linken Auge blind ist und nur ihrem
ideologischen Interessen folgt da
wundert mich gar nichts mehr meine man
kann über Bismarck mit Sicherheit
diskutieren aber ich glaube nicht dass
er Bücher gefälscht hat lebensläufige
fälscht hat meine Frau werbek möchte ja
auch vor vielen anlängst ablenken ich
hoffe bloß irgendwann dass wir auch mal
diese grüne Geschichte die sich jetzt
hier gerade in unserem Land breit macht
dieser grüner Sozialismus der hier
durchs Land getragen wird dass der auch
irgendwann mal aus unserem Verstand
gelöscht wird oder anders wann
entwickeln wir eigentlich wieder unseren
Verstand und Schreiben mal auf und sagen
es reicht wenn das was da passiert ist
unerträglich unsäglich aber das war
lange nicht die Spitze des Eisberges sie
werden immer weitermachen und setzen
darauf dass die Menschen das entweder
mitmachen oder sich vollkommen verblöten
lassen also ganz ehrlich ich frag mich
warum ist eigentlich keiner von diesen
Politikern hier und erklärt uns das mal
ganz einfach weil sie genau wissen dass
sie keine Erklärung für diesen
Schwachsinn haben aber sie machen ihn
weiter die Frage ist ob wir es weiter
ertragen und Mitmachen ich mache dabei
garantiert nicht weiter mit habe ich
sowieso nicht aber das liegt ja bei
jedem selbst ob du das gut findet und
wie die Politik da aufschreibt aber wir
haben garantiert wichtigere Probleme
schlimmere Probleme als diesen Mist den
sie da verzapfen aber dass er ablenken
wollen und sich wichtig tun wollen wird
wissen wir doch alle werden die Politik
hier am Tisch mit sitzen wir wollen
zumindest sie fragen Herr ist die
Politik dazu abgehoben erweckt man damit
den Eindruck dass man gar nicht die
wichtigen Probleme gerade auf der Agenda
hat ich glaube schon dass es bei großen
Teilen der grünen Politik auch eine
abgewohnheit gibt dass man mit den
echten Problemen draußen nichts mehr zu
tun haben will das ist ja auch eine
Elfenbein Turm Diskussion und wenn man
sich diesen Geschichtsrevisionismus
anguckt dass man einfach Teile der
deutschen Geschichte aus dem
öffentlichen Bewusstsein raushalten will
das ist ja auch eine Tendenz Frau Keller
zu Recht gesagt da wird einer kritischen
Auseinandersetzung jeder Boden entzogen
denn es wird einfach ein Teil unserer
Geschichte gelöscht und ich persönlich
kann nicht nachvollziehen warum unsere
Außenministerin in bundeseigenen
Gebäuden ein solchen
zumal ja sie auch jetzt nicht gesagt hat
es wären andere Persönlichkeit
vielleicht besser geeignet als Bismarck
sondern das ganze dann zum Saal der
deutschen Einheit zu machen das kann
doch keiner mehr nachvollziehen also mir
fehlt da jedes Verständnis für so eine
Geschichte es ist ja auch so dass die
Grünen in den Ländern auch hier in
Berlin ständig Straßen umbenennen
Kolonialismus zu Recht anprangern aber
eben dann aus dem öffentlichen
Bewusstsein aus der Stadt löschen ohne
dass diese kritische Auseinandersetzung
stattfinden und das ist ein großes
Problem
mit den Menschen kriegt man da irgendwie
so eine Art Schere auch in den Kopf dass
es Dinge gibt manche haben das Gefühl es
gab diese Studie auch man darf gar nicht
mehr das sagen man traut sich gewisse
Dinge nicht zu sagen was macht das mit
den Menschen psychologisch ist eine
weitere Verunsicherung und wir sind in
so vielen Punkten schon verunsichert und
sehr dünnhäutig geworden jetzt weiß man
nichtmals mehr ob man sich ein
Bismarckhering wahrscheinlich beizeiten
bestellen darf weil das wahrscheinlich
auch ein unangemessener Begriff ist dazu
bestellt das heißt also hier haben wir
eine große Herausforderung dass Menschen
weiter verunsichert werden in Dingen die
vertraut waren und umso weniger vertraut
es wir haben umso größer ist die
Belastung mit allen neuen das heißt wir
brauchen da eine emotionales
Gegengewicht und das wird genommen und
damit
stürzten viele Menschen immer weiter in
eine Krise es trägt also sagen sie zur
Verunsicherung weil man fragt sich auch
wo ist dann die Grenze also wo sagen wir
das aber jetzt mal Schluss das gehört zu
unserer deutschen Geschichte dazu damit
wollen wir uns auch auseinandersetzen wo
ziehen sie da die Grenze ich glaube dass
das ein Dolph hitler-platz den es in
Berlin ja auch gab oder Hermann Göring
oder ähnliches dass man das jetzt
ausreichend kritisch auch im Unterricht
behandelt dass auch jeder glaube ich
deutsche die Gelegenheit hat sich
darüber zu informieren wenn er denn oder
sie möchte aber da würde ich schon sagen
das brauchen wir tatsächlich in der
Öffentlichkeit da gibt es eine
hinreichende kritische
Auseinandersetzung aber gerade die
koloniale Vergangenheit Deutschlands
gerade eben auch das Deutsche Reich als
solches das sind alles Dinge mit denen
kann man sich denke ich auch kritisch
nachträglich auseinandersetzen das muss
man nicht löschen ähm Kinder
Nationalsozialismus darf man nicht
löschen und den Rest der Geschichte darf
man auch nicht löschen und deswegen
glaube ich sollten wir viel mehr die
kritische Auseinandersetzung suchen auch
die Grünen müssen lernen sich mit
anderen Meinungen auseinanderzusetzen
weil es ist ja der Meinungs Pluralismus
in der Gesellschaft der das Wesentliche
ist das Interessantes dabei
das ja auch die grüne Versuchung ihre
Pädophile politische Vergangenheit zu
löschen dass da keiner drüber redet was
sie in den neuen Jahr noch gefordert
haben Sex mit Kindern zu legalisieren
wollen wir das doch mal nicht vergessen
und wie weit haben Sie sich denn davon
weg bewegt im letzten Jahr haben wir
viel Gesetze zum Schutz der Kinder vor
kindesmissbrauchen die Bundestag
getragen und ich war daran beteiligt
Kinder Sexpuppen verboten Handbuch für
Pädophile verboten einen Tag ins
Führungszeugnis für Kinder schön erleben
lang und
Kinderpornografie zu Verbrechen so viel
dazu aber es waren zwei Parteien
darunter die Grünen und auch eine andere
Partei der sie angehören die sich den
Gesetzen bei der Abstimmung enthalten
haben und da frage ich mich natürlich
was hat man denn rausgelernt aus seiner
pädophilen Vergangenheit wenn man
gesetzlich zumindest missbraucht ich
habe jetzt die Vorhaben natürlich im
einzelnen nicht auf dem Schirm das muss
ich einräumen aber es ist natürlich so
wenn wir uns enthalten haben im
Bundestag dann gibt's dafür
höchstwahrscheinlich einen guten Grund
nämlich dass das Anliegen grundsätzlich
unterstützenswert war sonst würde man
sich nicht enthalten sondern dagegen
stimmen aber das ist wahrscheinlich
handwerkliche Schwierigkeiten gab das
wäre der Grund warum normalerweise nur
Enthaltungen im Bundestag stattfindet
also ich sag mal wahrscheinlich gab es
eine Einigkeit in der Zielrichtung aber
im Einzelnen oder in den Details
wahrscheinlich bei den Grünen gab es
keine Einigkeit so viel kann ich nicht
sagen gut dann ist das verständlich ich
glaube das Problem ist eigentlich das
überhaupt Menschen oder Politiker oder
eine Regierungsmitglieder glauben sie
hätten das Recht Geschicht zu löschen im
Nachhinein das ist eigentlich das
Grundproblem also woher kommt diese
Ambition also woher kommt ein denken
dass man glaubt man habe das Recht
historische Ereignisse für ungeschehen
zu erklären oder Personen für nicht
gelehrt also für für nicht existent zu
erklären um sie aus dem kollektiven
Gedächtnis zu löschen und das sehr leise
nein es ist aber genau das wie soll ich
sagen wenn Sie den Gründer also Bismarck
ist ja nicht irgendjemand im Auswärtigen
Amt sondern der Gründer des Auswärtigen
Amtes dass sie also man ist quasi dabei
den Gründer dieses Hauses aus dem Haus
zu verbannt entschuldigung das hat schon
einen einen ganz schönen beige Geschmack
ähm
das ist eine Ambition die man schlicht
untergreifend sagen wir mal unter
normalen in freiheitlichen
Gesellschaften sollte es überhaupt gar
keine Ambition geben Historie
ungeschehen also sozusagen aus dem aus
dem Bewusstsein der Menschen zu löschen
und das ist es ja im Endeffekt also
gerade eine Regierung wie die Grünen die
Grünen sind ja diejenigen die immer
sagen es ginge um visibility wenn es um
andere Themen geht die Sichtbarkeit der
Frau die Sichtbarkeit der Vielfalt der
Geschlechter dann kann man jetzt sagen
im Umkehrschluss machen sie gerade
Bismarck unsichtbar also sie machen und
deswegen weiß man eben auch sie machen
es sehr bewusst weil sie sonst nämlich
genau sehr großen Wert darauf legen dass
Dinge die Ihnen wichtig sind in der
Öffentlichkeit sichtbar sind im
Regierungsprogramm sichtbar sind und
hier werden jetzt Dinge gelöscht hier
werden Bibelzitate gelöscht hier werden
Kreuze abgehängt hier werden Personen
aus dem aus dem historischen Gedächtnis
gelöscht und mit Verlaub das ist total